and joining me now exclusively is
president Trump's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani all right mr. mayor Rubio says
take a chill pill basically this
subpoena for Don junior it's just
appalling part of just general generic
oversight what what's your reaction
tonight oh well I mean I respect both
senators very very much I've actually
campaigned for both of them I don't
understand what the oversight is I mean
he testified for 29 hours I think so
maybe there's a question or two that
wasn't asked they could you know send
him an interrogatory and get the answer
I don't know why you'd harass the man
more than you have I mean actually
mullet came to a pretty definitive
conclusion that Donald Trump jr. did
nothing wrong that there was no
suggestion that he would have any reason
to have believed that it was a violation
of the law to meet with that Russian
woman it turns out that the really
interesting part of that meeting is it
looks like a setup by a fusion GPS
because the woman met with Glenn Simpson
the head of that the day before the day
of and the day after they haven't
followed up I've been doing this a long
time and if that isn't a setup I'd be
really surprised I'd rather see them
into kind of look into that I don't know
what they could possibly ask Donald
Trump jr. that wasn't asked 9 hours you
know I think Rudy they're gonna talk it
sounds like the focus in part would be
on the discussions to build a Trump
Tower in Moscow before the election
actually took place but what is that we
get oversight that sounds like an
investment investigation again yeah it's
it's I got so many texts today from
friends who aren't really all that
political but they were just like I said
what this done it doesn't make sense to
us and I really didn't have a I didn't
really have a good answer for any of
them all right Rudy I have to bring this
up because I thought of you when I heard
that CNN was doing a town hall tonight
not with a 20/20 candidate but with your
favorite former FBI director Jim Comey
because yeah because he was out of the
redwood trees and he was marking his new
year
anniversary of being fired by President
Trump and listen because he's still not
over it you think he should be charged
when he's out of office
I think they saw what Muller has shown
well I think the Justice Department I'll
have to take a serious look at that
whether it's a wise thing to do to a
former president I don't know you think
the evidence is there to to prosecutors
sure looks like it's there with respect
to at least a couple of those episodes
of obstruction call me call me persist I
apologize for having hired him years ago
as an assistant US attorney
I am very embarrassed about that I don't
know what happened to Jim Comey but I
you know today's revelation by John
Solomon is a blockbuster
I mean it's it was clear to the State
Department that the Steele dossier was a
complete phony the memo was circulated
if he didn't read it he was sleeping and
you know I've read part of that dossier
and I've done this
Fiser stuff for years I was there when
it first started if you can't figure out
that the Steele dossier is a piece of
junk then you shouldn't be FBI director
I have no doubt that he's got a serious
problem having put his name on that
affidavit and not revealed that it was
unverified not revealed that he took no
steps to verify it when a State
Department employee was able to figure
out that Steele lied about there being a
consulate in Miami for for the Russian
government that Steele lied he hadn't
been in hadn't been in Moscow had been
Russia for nine years but why did they
keep using him why did why did the FBI
continue to rely on Christopher Steele
even after he broke the deal in the late
summer I believe he's in August of 2016
that you couldn't talk to the media he
broke the deal he was deemed unreliable
but then it looks like they still kept
using the fruits of his labor with this
dossier yeah and also in him during that
period Comey never attempted to verify
it he had five months to do it when he
went to the president in early January
of 2017 and said it's unverified and
salacious he had five months to verify
if he had verified
would have found out very easily but
there are five areas that were
absolutely untrue and he never revealed
to the court this was a paid for
political document by Hillary Clinton
this is outrageous all right Rudy I want
to move on to the backlash you've been
receiving for calling on the DOJ I guess
to investigate Biden and his family
you're not talked about this before on
the show and these questionable ties to
the Ukraine especially this sweetheart
paid a hunter Biden ended up getting
with it with a fun there here are just a
few of the examples let's listen
Giuliani the president's personal
attorney has been really pushing the
Justice Department to go hard on hunter
Biden's ties to Ukraine it is a bleep
move to use a foreign power to tarnish
Trump's potential general election
opponent Rudy Giuliani is telegraphing
it it's clearly hunter and in some ways
they almost want to create a foreign
interference throw in the Ukraine's and
Russians and Giuliani has been to the
Ukraine
he's got Ukrainian clients gets better
the New York Times posted this story
online quote Giuliani plans you can't
Ukraine trip to push for enquiries that
could help Trump like you you're not
allowed to travel apparently Rudy well
yeah I'm his lawyer one of the things
lawyers do when you defend a client is
to develop innocent hypotheses
explanations of what your client was
charged with well the fact is that this
was a massive collusion between the
Democratic National Committee officials
of the Obama administration Clinton
people and the Ukrainian officials
corrupt officials who by the way were
pro-russian corrupt officials to create
false information about Trump about
Manta fort this is this is real not
collusion conspiracy to present false
information and to leak it to the press
and to give it to the FBI the Ukrainian
government is presently investigating it
my aim is to make sure that soros
representatives who has a lot of
influence in that government and a very
highly corrupt Ukrainian who actually
participated in creating a false
document about Paul Manafort actually
he's been found guilty of that by a
Ukrainian court I thought that they do
not prevent the continuation of this
investigation which they are trying to
do all I want the Ukrainian government
to do is investigate and don't let these
people Buffalo you and that's what
they're trying to do why isn't the media
pursuing this this it's the media's
collusion why not this I mean it's it's
a fascinating story and everyone is a
big story it's a dramatic story and I
guarantee you Joe Biden will not get to
Election Day without this being
investigated not because I want to see
him investigated this is collateral to
what I was doing but here are the facts
Laura Joe Biden was appointed the point
man for Ukraine two to three weeks later
his son hunter who had just been tossed
out of the military for testing positive
to cocaine was appointed to a position
on the most corrupt agency or the most
corrupt business in Ukraine a natural
gas business called barista which was
headed by an oligarch who was being
protected by Putin in Russia and Biden's
kid took down about three to four
million dollars we can count and Biden
when the kid got under investigation
actually says quote i strong-armed the
president of the Ukraine to dismiss the
prosecutor because the son of a leave it
out was corrupt what he left out of the
explanation was that prosecutor was
right on the tail of his son looking for
the money that appeared to have been
laundered from Latvia to Croatia to
America and when he tried to get the
Croatian government to give the amount
of money that hunter
iDEN received all of a sudden the
president of the Ukraine gets a call
from the vice president United States
and he's told you're not gonna get you
1.2 billion dollar loan guarantee which
they needed then to prevent default
unless you dismiss the prosecutor the
president didn't want to do it he was
the Godfather of the prosecutors
children he didn't want to do it this is
like this is like a Janus years novel
now if you tell me this doesn't get
investigated between now and Election
Day
then our justice system is corrupt
Donald Trump and Donald Trump jr. I'll
be on the front page of every one of
those newspapers
for the last four weeks the best
evidence I've seen of media corruption
well I'm Rudy I want to get back to call
me because more is coming in about what
he said tonight and he said that and
this kind of goes in line with this
letter from over 800 former prosecutors
who said that they think the conduct of
Trump is described in Mulla report does
amount to obstruction of justice but he
specifically was asked if he believed
that the president obstructed justice
let's listen you think he had criminal
10 based on what you have seen now in
the Muller report it sure looks like he
did in connection with a couple episodes
the direction to Don Mahan to get the
special counsel fired is to my mind a
flaming example of Rob's intent yes of
corrupt intent this is a guy Laura who
couldn't make a corruption case when
33,000 emails were deleted cell phones
were destroyed with hammers and servers
were bleached and he couldn't make a
corruption case based on that that's
corruption when you destroy evidence
this is a case in which the president
was innocent of the underlying charges
and he was defending himself against
malicious looks to me like very
well-organized corrupt charges against
himself
no prosecutor in the world would bring
this case and the people they got to
sign that I guarantee you there's not a
single one that voted for Donald Trump
and I've never heard of prosecutors
opining in case they don't know about
that's a political statement that's not
a prosecutorial memo and they should be
ashamed of themselves they don't know a
damn thing about this case and all they
know is what they read in the newspapers
and what they get from a highly biased
report a 440 page diatribe that is a
complete violation of prosecutorial
ethics yeah what I what I think is it
tells me once again why I don't trust a
lot of prosecutors today sorry I mean I
well please I was one and I have a lot
of good friends who were know you and
some of these people work for me and I'm
ashamed of them because you do not offer
an opinion based on a case you didn't
investigate if you do you are doing a
political statement not a legal memo
it's a scandal mr. mayor I know you
could have gone on a lot of shows we
really appreciate well I guarantee you
this will be eventually investigated and
it will be a massive scandal you can't
escape the facts I've seen them I've
seen the corroboration I've seen tapes
this is a very random you know big case
and a disgraceful discretional misuse of
our law enforcement evenings we gotta go
and our intelligence agencies at the
very top all right Rudy thank you so
much